Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, my Season 4
countdown continues.
Also if you hadn’t noticed, I just changed
my youtube avatar.
It’s just meant to look a little bit more
like my face.
This time I’ll be talking about my Top 10
characters on the show.
Especially given where things are headed in
season 4.
My biggest favorites always get shuffled a
little based on what happens each season,
so people that were my favorite in season
1 might be lower on the list right now.
All that being said, as I work my way down
the list to my own number one.
Here’s the biggest question we need to answer.
Who is the most important character in A Song
of Ice and Fire?
Not the coolest or most powerful, the most
important.
Like if you were forced to say who the one
main character is after everything is done.
This would be that person.
So as you think about that, also think about
this.
Is the most important character the person
that ends up on the Iron Throne, or is it
the person that put them there.
So real quick before we try to answer that
question.
I’m going to do one more countdown video
tomorrow morning and then my next video will
be my review of Episode 1.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I’m doing a weekly giveaway.
The winner is picked at random from the comments.
All you have to do is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on my review video each week.
I’ll explain more tomorrow.
Now, let’s get started.
Dragons are coming.
And Winter.
Here’s my Top 10 Characters going into Season
4.
Careful for potential spoilers if you’re
not caught up on Season 3.
Number 10 - Daario.
I guess you could say the new Daario since
we’re also talking about actors.
He mostly makes the list because the character
is such a big part of Daenerys story and she’s
also on this list.
I feel like the people who are most important
to the most important people are sometimes
also the most interesting characters.
Daario as we’ve seen him so far is essentially
the special forces leader of Daenerys Army.
Yes Grey Worm is technically the leader of
the Army, but Daario is the person she calls
on for the most important political missions
and doing covert dirty work.
The swagger the character has is also a lot
of fun given how proper the rest of Dany’s
inner circle is.
You have two knights who are almost Yes Men
and a few influential women.
Daario is one of the few people that kind
of just does what Daario wants to do.
Adding Sex into the equation makes his relationship
with Dany and the dynamic between him and
her other male advisors a little funny too.
I’m hoping that since they went through
through the trouble to recast the role, they
added a lot more of his book scenes.
We’ve already seen a clip of him and it’s
very promising.
Number 9 - Sansa Stark.
Someone who you might write off because of
how much shit she’s taken from the Lannisters,
but I think she’s going to surprise us.
We also have to acknowledge how much Sophie
Turner has matured as an actress since the
show has started.
I feel like they keep giving Sansa more to
do each season because Sophie Turner has become
so much more compelling as things get worse
for her character.
I will say that I love tv show Sansa a lot
more than book Sansa, and that’s all because
of Sophie.
One of my other favorite things about her
is that because she’s quote unquote a flower,
other characters tend to overlook her.
So she gets to be present for some of the
biggest and best scenes just because no one
is really paying attention to her.
With the exception of Joffrey.
I’m most looking forward to seeing how Sophie
Turner interprets Sansa as all these new Season
4 mega events unfold.
And the really cool thing for all the book
readers out there is that she’s a POV character
in Winds of Winter.
They haven’t posted any excerpts for her
yet though.
Number 8 - Melisandre.
The Lady in Red.
Even though Daenerys brought dragons back
into the world, Melisandre is the most visible
symbol of magic on the show.
She’s add this whole sex aspect to it that
really makes you afraid and turned on at the
same time.
Like imagine how Gendry felt with the sex
leeches.
Disgusting, terrifying and awesome at the
same time.
She’s also one of the wisest characters
on the show next to Tyrion and Varys.
She really is like a female Maester who’s
not a Maester.
They really teased the Wall during that last
scene at Dragonstone in Season 3.
So what I’m most looking forward to from
her is seeing how she interacts with Jon Snow.
And watching him react to her will also be
so much fun.
He has a very spotty track record with sexy
gingers.
Number 7 - Oberyn Martell, the Red Viper of
Dorne.
For a lot of people who haven’t read the
books he’s a totally new character.
Which is one of the reasons I like him so
much.
He’s fresh meat for the King’s Landing
grinder.
He also brings Dorne into the story in a much
bigger way.
It’s a whole region of Westeros we haven’t
seen yet.
One of the coolest things about big epic stories
like Ice and Fire is that they’re literally
big places.
So you don’t just get stuck with the same
group of characters for 7 or 8 seasons.
Of all the new characters coming in the near
future.
He’s one of the best.
I really hope we see more Dorne in season
5, but this year I’m most looking forward
to watching him fight.
That’s essentially what his reputation is,
being one of the best fighters in Westeros.
And because of the different culture, he fights
in this really cool way none of the other
knights of King’s Landing do.
We actually got some teasers for this in all
the trailers they’ve been posting.
Number 6 - Brienne of Tarth.
Probably the only real knight in Westeros.
Brienne was so awesome in season 3 and watching
Gwendoline Christie with Nikolaj Coster-Waldau
was one of my favorite things.
I could watch a whole season of just the two
of them together.
World’s best odd couple.
Brienne is probably the most noble person
in Westeros.
Even in the first episode you got the sense
that just because people were knights, didn’t
mean they were honorable.
Playing the Game of Thrones and all.
But Brienne is one of the only characters
that doesn’t care about any of that.
She has this beautiful dream of knighthood
and it’s works so well when you juxtapose
it with someone like Jaime Lannister, who
essentially doesn’t care about anything.
I think he thinks he cares about Cersei, but
he has doubts about even that.
So it’s like Pure belief and Nhilism walking
around together.
The think I’m most looking forward to for
her in season 4 is seeing her adapt to the
rewards and challenges of King’s Landing.
She largely gets credit for bringing Jaime
back and as much as she rubbed of on him.
I can’t wait to see him try to repay her.
Number 5 - Arya Stark.
Stabby Death Machine in training.
All of the clips of Arya that we’ve seen
from the trailers have been action scenes
and her in the middle of a warrior training
montage with Needle.
I just love how dark she is, it’s this whole
level of complexity that Sansa hasn’t quite
got to and something that goes way beyond
where Jon Snow or Bran are.
Despite all those characters have been through.
She’s one of the few characters on the show
that embraces the direction she’s headed.
Revenge Machine.
How appropriate that we saw the Titan of Braavos
in one of the trailers.
Kind of heralding the return of faceless ones.
You also can’t talk about her right now
without talking about the houd.
Of all the twosomes on the show.
She and the Hound are my second favorite behind
Jaime and Brienne.
It says a lot about who the strongest characters
are when you see who rubs off on who.
For instance, Brienne is a much stronger character
than Jaime right now.
So she rubs off on him.
And Arya is a much stronger character than
the hound.
In an intense dark way.
So she rubs off on him.
It’s just so funny and awesome to think
that such a young small character has a stronger
presence than someone as vicious as The Hound.
Number 4 - Jon Snow.
He’s a real fan favorite because Kit Harington
is so awesome and because the character has
so much potential.
There’s a lot of things in the story that
make you feel like he’s destined for greatness.
So he’s in my Top 5 mostly because I feel
like he’s going to be one of the focal points
of the story as things move into Winds of
Winter.
One of the biggest problems of Season 3 was
that he was off on his own with the Wildlings.
Yes, it was so much fun watching him react
to Ygritte.
Guess which one of them had the stronger personality.
But he didn’t really get to interact with
any of the other characters.
I liked Ciaran Hinds as Mance Rayder, but
he was barely there.
And a lot of the Wildlings with the exception
of Ygritte and the Lord of Bones were forgettable.
Giants notwithstanding.
The thing I’m most looking forward to from
him in season 4 is taking more of a leadership
role.
It’s time to grow up boy.
We’ve already seen him with Sam in the Night’s
Watch library.
So I can’t wait to see them deal with the
Wildling army, angry ex girlfriends and hopefully
some more white walkers.
Number 3 - Tyrion Lannister
I really do feel like once we get through
Season 4 he’ll be one of the most important
characters, but this year it looks like he’s
going to be hanging out in the black cells.
And he can’t start having a greater impact
until he gets out.
Tyrion is one of the most interesting characters
on the show just in general for two big reasons.
One George RR Martin has said that he identifies
with him the most, so I feel like he expresses
the character in a much deeper way.
And two, Peter Dinklage is one of the best
actors on the show.
There was this really cool thing that Dinklage
said about acting in an sword and sandal show
like Game of Thrones.
He said that because it’s such a grand setting,
actors tend to overdo their performance a
lot.
Like cranking the acting knob to 11.
But he has this subtle way of delivering lines
or saying things using gestures that just
comes across so much more effectively than
yelling your lines ever could.
That’s why I feel like HBO kind of makes
him one of the centerpieces of the show, from
a marketing stand point.
Next to Emilia Clarke.
The thing I’m most looking forward to from
Tyrion in Season 4 is repaying all his debts.
Because a Lannister always repays his debts.
Sometimes with revenge.
Number 2 - Jaime Lannister.
There has been so much Jaime in all the trailers
that I feel like he more than anyone with
the exception of Tyrion will be the biggest
character in King’s Landing.
Yes Purple Wedding, but think about the entire
season.
As of the end of Season 3, he’s undergone
one of the biggest character transformations
next to Theon.
There’s so much of Brienne’s nobility
in him now I can’t wait to see how he deals
with all the shit going down in King’s Landing.
The Golden hand is just the icing on the cake.
It’s just a visual sign of his transformation.
There’s oathkeeper and the White Cloaks.
Mark my words.
By the end of Season 4, Jaime will be one
of your favorite characters if he’s not
already.
I’m most interested to see how he deals
with all the changes happening in King’s
Landing.
Like Cersei, who’s kind of changing herself.
He’s going to be leading the White Cloaks
too.
I don’t think he’s going to become another
Barristan Selmy, but I do think he’s trying
to be the kind of person Brienne would respect
and admire.
Plus there’s him learning to fight with
his left hand.
I can’t wait to see him train with Bronn.
They changed that from the books for anyone
who’s wondering.
Number 1 - Daenerys
Just talking about Season 4, I feel like she’s
going to be the biggest and most important.
Joffrey is King of Westeros, but he’s really
just a figurehead.
Daenerys is earning her kingdom, one freed
slave at a time.
Then there’s the dragons.
Of all the things HBO pumped up in the trailers
it was the size of the dragons now.
Even on the Black Friday South Park episode
it was all about ‘dragons are coming’.
They’re collectively always going to be
at least the second most important characters
in A Song of Ice And Fire no matter what happens.
It will be like Dany is the biggest, the Tyrion
or Jon Snow.
And always right behind them Dragons.
If you wanted to get someone excited about
the show who hadn’t seen it all you would
have to say would be “Dragons are coming.”
And they would totally get it.
The thing I’m most looking forward to from
Daenerys in Season 4 is her trying to be a
real queen.
Not just a General like she was in season
3.
That story arc was all about conquering, but
now she actually has to learn to rule.
Think of it as a like a practice run for the
Iron Throne.
Emilia Clarke has done such an amazing job
of portraying someone who is essentially a
little girl learning to be a general, then
the mother of dragons and now a queen on top
of all that.
Remember Dany isn’t a lot older than Arya.
But now it’s your turn, let me know who
your favorite character is right now and who
your favorite actor is.
It doesn’t have to be the same person.
Tomorrow morning I’ll post my Top 10 Moments
from Season 3 and then my episode 1 review
that night.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
participate in the giveaway.
Right now click here for all the rest of my
countdown videos and click here to watch all
my trailer breakdowns.
Dragons are coming.
Tomorrow.
High Fives everyone.
The wait is over.